[Music]
you know it seems like nearly every day
a new name is being added to the list of
Hollywood stars and power players who
stand accused of sexual misconduct today
six-time Emmy award-winning comedian
louis c.k responded to allegations
leveled against him admitting that
everything his accusers claimed is true
louis c.k says these stories are true
the embattled comedian confesses with
shame to the New York Times story that
five women accused him of sexual
misconduct his statement reads in part
at the time I said to myself that what I
did was okay the power I had over these
women is that they admired me and I
wielded that power irresponsibly there
is nothing about this that I forgive
myself for and I have to reconcile it
with Who I am which is nothing compared
to the task I left them with CK's career
is collapsing his movie I love you daddy
is dead the distributor pulled the plug
today none of that is my fault the
shelving follows the cancellation of the
movie's New York premiere last night and
now a rep for co-star Chloe grace Moretz
confirms to ET that the actress pulled
out of promoting the movie two weeks ago
after first becoming aware of potential
allegations against louis c.k also for
those of you tuning in to see my
interview with louis c.k tonight i have
some bad news
CK canceled his appearance on The Late
Show with Stephen Colbert last night and
today FX networks ended its association
with the comedian Netflix said it will
not be moving forward with a new
stand-up special and HBO is cutting ties
heartbreaking it's just truly
heartbreaking Judd Apatow a fellow
comedian and filmmaker told et all of
this can cause a shift well there's more
women in show business there'll be a lot
less of this we have to have more women
in power
you